[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen so
knapp 20 minuten mit den wichtigsten
themen heute fußball noch mehr gibt es
von norbert leber als schimpfwort
familie und wir blicken unter anderem
auf den ukraine krieg
schwere kämpfe in der ost ukraine
russland rückt im don was for president
see lance gefordert im zdf-interview
mehr unterstützung aus deutschland
mehr missbrauchsfälle in münster eine
studie dokumentiert über 600 opfer sie
wirft dem bistum jahrzehntelange
vertuschung vor
und gegen italien soll ein sieg her die
nationalmannschaft will morgen mit einem
erfolgserlebnis in die sommerpause gehen
im umkämpften don was machen die
russischen truppen geländegewinne auch
bei der einnahme der strategisch
wichtigen stadt severo donetsk für die
ukraine wird es militärisch immer
schwieriger den angriffen stand zu
halten in kiew konnte das zdf heute
exklusiv ein interview mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten seelands
gefahren die natur schicken berichtet
kiew heute vormittag heute journal
moderator christian sievers im interview
mit präsident selensky 30 minuten
sprechen sie inklusive einer klaren
forderung seelands keys an den deutschen
bundeskanzler
wir brauchen von kanzler scholz die
sicherheit dass deutschland die ukraine
unterstützt er und seine regierung
müssen sich entscheiden es darf kein
spagat versucht werden zwischen der
ukraine und den beziehungen zu russland
kritik auch beim thema waffenlieferungen
deutschland habe erst sehr spät
gehandelt
als erste waren da die usa die
tschechien großbritannien polen
bulgarien die baltischen staaten
deutschland und frankreich waren später
dran und das ist die wahrheit sie haben
erst mal politische und diplomatische
unterstützung zugesagt aber damals am
anfang des krieges brauchten wir nicht
die politik sondern die hilfe
ein besuch scholz in der hauptstadt wäre
ein signal bei den menschen in kiew
stößt das auf ein geteiltes echo
er soll hierher kommen und selbst sehen
wie es hier aussieht das eine ist die
dinge im fernsehen zu sehen das andere
ist sie selbst zu erleben sie kommen
doch alle ich habe aber nicht das gefühl
dass das irgendetwas ändert die gefechte
vor allem im donbass gehen unvermindert
weiter die strategisch wichtige stadt
cebu donetsk ist so gut wie eingenommen
alle brücken die in die stadt führen
sollen zerstört sein heißt es am abend
russland zeigt unterdessen bilder auf
denen sie erbeutete munition
präsentieren darunter auch panzer
abwehrwaffen vom typ milan sowie sie
auch die bundeswehr derzeit nutzt
110 tage krieg 110 tage die präsident
see lenski verändert haben wie er sagt
ich bin vom friedens zum
kriegspräsidenten geworden ich darf
keine zweifel haben ich muss agieren
wenn ich heute zugeständnisse machen
würde verlieren wir auf jeden fall
deshalb bieten sie auch heute
erbitterten widerstand in einem krieg
der verändert nicht nur den präsidenten
ja wir haben hier gerade eben beitrag
gesehen christian sievers ist zurzeit in
kiew und hat das interview mit dem
ukrainischen präsidenten geführt
christian wie hast du sie lenski erlebt
jaja er kam mir sehr kontrolliert vor
und zwar sowohl inhaltlich es gibt
manche fragen auf die überlegte erst
sehr lange bevor er antwortet als auch
von der optik wir haben das interview in
seinem lagezentrum geführt das muss man
sich quasi wie so ein hauptquartier
eines internet startups vorstellen sehr
modern und sehr cool auch auf eine art
aber drumherum da ist dieser
präsidentenpalast und das ist klassische
alte sowjetische architektur sehr dunkel
sehr düster und jetzt aktuell überall
sandsäcke vor den fenstern die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen enorm details
über die sicherheitsvorkehrungen sollen
auf keinen fall veröffentlicht werden
man merkt also es macht einen schon sehr
beklommen dort der präsident hat viele
junge mitarbeiter aber wir sehen bei
denen auch schon ringe unter den augen
man merkt also die situation geht an
niemandem ihr vorbei auch nicht am
präsidenten und seinen leuten einzel es
gibt ja immer wieder besuch aus dem
ausland jetzt gibt es berichte dass
kanzler scholz zusammen mit dem
französischen präsidenten makro und dem
italienischen ministerpräsidenten draghi
lenski kommt was wirst du dazu
also das wird hier zumindest von
niemandem dementiert auch nicht von
präsident selensky selbst es gibt hier
so ein bisschen die hoffnung dass wenn
alle drei kommen würden also draghi
makro und stolz dass die drei dann nicht
daran vorbeikommen würden der ukraine
zumindest ein positives signal zu geben
hin auf einen kandidatenstatus für einen
möglichen beitritt in die eu und egal
mit wem man hier spricht diesen
eu-beitritt diesen möglichen eu-beitritt
in der zukunft den wollen sie alle auch
der präsident einschätzung eindrücke aus
care von christian sie war es dankeschön
ja und ganz ausführlich gibt's das
interview mit präsident seelands geben
heute journal um 21.45 und dann auch in
der zdf- heute- app
präsident jens gefordert also mehr
unterstützung von deutschland vor der
reise des kanzlers in die ukraine auch
die unionsfraktion will den druck auf
die ampel koalition erhöhen was die
lieferung schwerer waffen angeht sie
bereitet einen antrag vor in dem sie
fordert den gemeinsamen bundestags
beschluss zu den waffenlieferungen voll
umzusetzen
die regierung würde dies bisher ich tun
ein bericht von andrea maurer
seit sich die hinweise verdichten dass
er womöglich noch diese woche in die
ukraine fährt geht es auch um die frage
was bringt der kanzler mit nach kiew aus
dem kanzleramt dazu bisher keine
informationen auch die reise selbst will
der regierungssprecher nicht bestätigen
wohl auch aus sicherheitsgründen deshalb
bleibe ich doch heute ganz konsequent
bei dem satz dass ich ihnen hier
zunächst nur aus berichten
was die ukraine braucht listet der
berater des ukrainischen präsidenten
heute auf 1000 hobbits 300 mehrfach
raketenwerfer 500 panzer 2000 gepanzerte
fahrzeuge 1000 drohen immer mehr rückt
auch in den fokus was deutschland bisher
geliefert oder nicht geliefert hat auf
anfrage der linken-abgeordneten serien
daten lernen nennt das
wirtschaftsministerium diese zahl des
ersten juni wurden rüstungsgüter im wert
von 305 millionen euro genehmigt wenig
im vergleich zu den usa mit 4,6
milliarden dollar und schwere waffen wie
artillerie geschütze und flugabwehr
panzer wurden bisher zwar zugesagt aber
noch nicht geliefert der kasseler
reagiert heute auf kritik es geht hier
nicht um presseerklärung es geht um
richtig schweres gerät das muss man
benutzen können dafür muss man trainiert
werden das findet in der bundesrepublik
deutschland gegenwärtig stadt und
diejenigen die daran trainiert werden
wissen genau warum das so ist es ist
nämlich wirklich schwer und es ist
wirklich hoch effizient was wir dort zur
verfügung stellen werden die union
erhöht im vorfeld einer möglichen reise
den druck auf scholz ein reiner besuch
dort des guten willens reicht nicht aus
sondern es muss auch tatsächlich etwas
buchstäblich im gepäck sein also
entsprechende waffenlieferungen
beschlossen sein umgesetzt sein in dem
augenblick wo man in kiew auftritt sonst
wird man sich dort unangenehme fragen
gefallen lassen und im übrigen auch
unangenehme fragen im deutschen
bundestag die erwartungen sind hoch auch
um den eu kandidatenstatus für die
ukraine dürfte es bei einer kanzlei
reise nach kiew wohl gehen
wegen des ukraine krieges will
deutschland ja auch energielieferungen
aus russland verzichten das ist eine
herausforderung fürs ganze land und
gerade auch für die ostdeutschen
bundesländer mit raffinerien um deren
zukunft ging es unter anderem heute beim
treffen der ministerpräsidentin neuen
präsidenten aus deutschlands auch der
kanzler kam dazu die einzelheiten von
plan mosebach
landung des kanzlers auf der ostseeinsel
riems das forschungsinstitut des bundes
für tiergesundheit haben sich die
ostdeutschen regierungschefinnen und
chefs ausgesucht für ihre beratung
zentrales thema energiesicherheit
besonders der osten war bisher
angewiesen auf öl und gas aus russland
nur mit erneuerbarer energie
da waren sich die ministerpräsidenten
einig kann es echte unabhängigkeit geben
bei der transformation zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft kann aus
deutschland eine führende rolle
einnehmen insbesondere die erneuerbaren
energien das thema wasserstoff bieten
für die ostdeutschen länder große chance
und uns geht es jetzt darum dass wir im
bund aber auch in der europäischen union
eine interessenvertretung haben wollen
oder haben wir uns heute verständigt wir
schließen uns zusammen wir finanzieren
die gemeinsam die ostdeutschen
bundesländer und wir haben von der
bundesregierung die zusage dass sie uns
bei der finanzierung hilft bei der
unabhängigkeit von russischem öl stehen
die ostdeutschen raffinerie in leuna und
vor allem schwebt im fokus bisher
beliefert und betrieben von russland die
pipeline zum rostocker hafen könnte den
größten teil der kapazitäten übernehmen
die restlichen mengen sollten dann über
eine leitung aus polen zugeführt werden
was werden die polen aber nur machen
wenn das geld das damit verdient wird
nicht bei rosneft also bei putin landet
eine forderung haben die aus deutschen
länderchefs dem kanzler noch mit auf den
weg gegeben
ist immer noch eine region in
deutschland wo viele menschen kleine und
mittlere einkommen haben und deshalb ist
es uns natürlich auch wichtig dass
energiepreise bezahlbar bleiben die
kosten der unabhängigkeit von russischer
energie so der pilger
ministerpräsidenten sollen für die
verbraucher beherrschbar bleiben in ost
und west
die expertinnen und experten vom
stockholmer friedensforschungsinstitut
sipri gehen davon aus dass atomwaffen in
den nächsten jahrzehnten wieder eine
größere rolle spielen werden das sei ein
sehr beunruhigender trend zwar seien die
bestände zuletzt leicht zurückgegangen
das bleibe aber nicht so laut sie
befinden sich mehr als 90 prozent
nuklearwaffen im besitz der usa und
russlands
das ausmaß der sexualisierten gewalt im
katholischen bistum münster ist deutlich
größer als bisher bekannt mehr als 600
kinder sind davon betroffen gewesen so
eine heute veröffentlichte studie
und das sind nur die fälle die sich aus
den akten des bistums ergeben so gehen
die forschenden von 5000 bis 6000
betroffenen mädchen und jungen aus viele
der täter seien wiederholungstäter
gewesen und deren taten von dem bischöfe
vertuscht worden dort die färber
berichtet
zehn jahre alt war martin schmitt als
der pfarrer in rhede erstmals
übergriffig wurde jahrelang wurde der
messdiener missbraucht die erinnerungen
dauern an
dann ging es weiter da drüben im
pfarrhaus dass das dann irgendwann wie
selbstverständlich seine hand in meine
hose wandert und es ging daneben weiter
das ist wirklich in ferienlagern zu
massiven übergriffen kann solche taten
im märz bistum münster sind von
wissenschaftlern untersucht worden
umfassend von 1945 bis 2020 eine bilanz
des schreckens
610 jungen und mädchen wurden
nachweislich missbraucht die
dunkelziffer dürfte viel höher liegen
mutmaßlich bis zu 6000 kinder und
jugendliche fast 200 männer der kirche
werden als täter beschuldigt der
missbrauch flächendeckend von
einzelfällen kann also keine rede sein
die bischöfe waren insgesamt über diese
vorkommen dass durchaus breit informiert
der amtierende münsteraner bischof felix
genn nimmt die studie entgegen will sich
später äußern auch gern werden darin
fehler bescheinigt schuldige hirten
bischöfe und vikare die ihren mitbrüdern
gegenüber er seelsorger als
dienstvorgesetzte waren
finden nicht gut was du tust aber im
zweifel lieber mit bruder hauen wir dich
da raus auf diese weise wurde die
katholische kirche zur täter institution
immerhin wird im bistum münster jetzt
konsequenter vorgegangen ein kleiner
lichtblick für die vielen betroffenen
um kinder im netz besser zu schützen
fordert die missbrauchsbeauftragte der
bundesregierung kerstin klaus jetz von
betreibern von chats für minderjährige
mehr kontrollen der betreiber muss
sicherstellen dass das kind wirklich
erst 13 jahre alt ist und nicht doch 43
sie müssen also ein nachweis für die
identifikation der person fordern bevor
jemand dort chatton darf sagte klaus
auch ein schutzraum für kinder sollen
kitas seien ein ort für betreuung und
bildung aber das angebot für die 3,2
millionen kinder bis zur einstellung
lässt offenbar zu wünschen übrig das
jedenfalls zeigt eine aktuelle umfrage
unter kita kräften zwei drittel stellen
fest dass es zu wenige betreuungsplätze
gibt weit mehr als die hälfte sagen sie
können den bedürfnissen der kinder nicht
gerecht werden weil personal fehlt und
den ärmeren wohngegenden heißt es bei
fast der hälfte der kitas für
ausgewogene ernährung fehlt das geld
sven glas
sie tun alles damit die kinder nicht
spüren wie sehr sie auch in dieser kita
in stuttgart personell am limit sind wie
stressig der job für die erzieherinnen
ist
es fehlen personal egal wie gut man das
versucht es hinzukriegen es ist
schwierig mindestens eine fachkraft mehr
bräuchten sie hier pro gruppe doch die
suche ist extrem kompliziert die
öffnungszeiten mussten sie deshalb schon
reduzieren an der kita die ein von den
eltern getragener verein betreibt und es
gibt tatsächlich aber auch einzelne tage
wo wir die kinder gar nicht bringen
können weil einfach die betreuung nicht
gewährleistet ist der erzieher engpass
dürfte sich noch verschärfen
140.000 zusätzliche kita-plätze könnten
demnächst für geflüchtete kinder aus der
ukraine benötigt werden prognostiziert
der städte und gemeindebund
schon ohne diese zusätzlichen kinder
fehlt es massiv an fachkräften sagt die
gewerkschaft wenn du den bedarf auf
bundesebene erzieherinnen und erziehern
also im pädagogischen fachkräften
ausgleichen wollte und zwar so dass die
wissenschaftler empfehlung gehalten
werden kann hätten und bedarf und
350.000 zusätzlichen erzieher und
erzielen eine riesige aufgabe vor der
kita träger aber auch die
kultusministerien der länder stehen
beispiel baden württemberg wir sind dran
und wir sind auch konkret an der
überlegung fürs nächste kindergartenjahr
gerade weil die flüchtlinge aus der
ukraine natürlich nochmal zusätzlichen
bedarf auslösen mehr anerkennung und
mehr geld für den anspruchsvollen und
verantwortungsvollen job fordern sie
hier in stuttgart damit mehr menschen
sich für den erzieherberuf entscheiden
frankreichs präsident marco muss nach
der ersten runde der parlamentswahl um
die absolute mehrheit bangen dem auch
künftig unterstützung für seine
regierung und reformpläne sichern soll
das liberale parteien bündnis des
präsidenten lang quasi gleichauf mit der
allianz um den linkspolitiker wähler
entscheiden für die mehrheit in der
nationalversammlung ist die stichwahl
zwischen beiden lagern am nächsten
sonntag
der brh exit und die damit verbundene
nordirland frage sorgen für neuen streit
zwischen der eu und großbritannien die
britische regierung will per gesetz
teile der bisherigen vereinbarungen
aushebeln so sollen die kontrollen
zwischen nordirland und den westlichen
großbritannien wegfallen die eu lehnt
änderungen an dem mühsam ausgehandelten
abkommen ab es soll verhindern dass
zwischen dem eu mitglied irland und im
britischen nordirland eine harte grenze
entsteht
chinas regierung wird politik bringt
wieder einschränkungen für millionen von
menschen diesmal in peking nachdem ein
infizierter an einer beliebten bar
offenbar hunderte menschen an steckte
werden weite teile des betroffenen
stadtteils amt viele läden und
restaurants schließen menschen müssen zu
hause bleiben 3 5 millionen bewohner
müssen sich auf den co wieder reger
testen lassen
um kommerz um sport zu fuß bei nations
league norbert morgen abend deutschland
gegen italien aber bitte nicht schon
wieder viermal in folge eins zu eins da
sehen sich natürlich auch bundestrainer
hansi flick nach einem sieg und geht wie
er selbst sagt sehr positiv gestimmt in
das letzte länderspiel der saison alle
25 spieler des kaders sind fit und
motiviert
das abschlusstraining in budapest war
nicht ganz so anstrengend doch die zeit
der sieglosigkeit macht keinen spaß man
könnte auch sagen viermal reni das tut
weh mit tun die vier unentschieden ja
ich finde es einfach nicht gut ja warum
das mal milde auszudrücken weil ich
gewinnen möchte und ich denke vielen
spielern im team geht es genauso das
vierte spiel in zehn tagen zu hause
gegen den europameister soll jetzt
bringen was bislang fehlte dieser
panisch hat einfach gefehlt dass wir
irgendwie ein erfolgserlebnis zusammen
erleben dass uns das so ein bisschen
mehr nach vorne bringt mit einem sieg
gegen italien könnte das team auf platz
1 der nations league gruppe in die
sommerpause gehen und
das spiel morgen abend live zu sehen bei
uns im zdf ab 20 uhr 15 von den männern
zu den deutschen fußball-frauen da steht
ja die em in england vor der tür das
team von trainerin martina voss
tecklenburg bereitet sich wie zuvor auch
die männer in herzogenaurach auf das
turnier vor
noch sind es die kleinen spiegel geübt
wird auf mini tore die bundestrainerin
sortiert hütchen vorbereitungen aufs
große turnier die fußball frauen
nationalmannschaft erhöht langsam die
schlagzahl vor der em steht die
vorfreude gerade im vordergrund vor der
anspannung natürlich spiel war schon ein
gewisses kribbeln aber sind noch ein
paar wochen hin im letzten spiel haben
noch die serbinnen gejubelt im juli auf
der insel wollen und müssen die dfb
frauen wieder selbst treffen für das
darf und team heißt es jetzt in die
pedale treten und meter machen um dann
in england weit zu kommen
bei der para schwimmen wm auf madeira
tanja scholz die erste deutsche
goldmedaille geholt die
querschnittsgelähmte elmshornerin gewann
in ihrer paradedisziplin über 100 meter
freistehend vor den schwimmerinnen aus
brasilien ja nur eine halbe stunde
später holte sie auch noch silber über
die 150 meter lagenstrecke starkes wm
debüt der 37 jährigen vor zwei jahren
querschnittslähmungen nach einem
reitunfall und jetzt mischt den fahrer
schwimmen die weltspitze aufmischen
danke schön aber wir blicken zum schluss
noch nach spanien auf etwas was uns hier
noch bevorsteht und das ist enorme hitze
in manchen teilen des landes schwitzten
die menschen bei bis zu 43 grad fast
schon angenehm ist es dann an den
stränden auf mallorca am mittwoch nur 35
grad und so heißt könnte es am kommenden
wochenende auch bei uns werden in dieser
woche wird es von tag zu tag heißer dazu
auch sehr sonnig märz um besser gleich
von katja honnefer marietta slomka
begrüßte um 21 45 zum heute journal
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend das war sehr heiß heute in
spanien mit höchsttemperaturen von 39
bis 43 grad deutlich angenehmer war es
da doch hier bei uns in mitteleuropa mit
20 bis 23 grad und in der kommenden
nacht wird ist richtig frisch die
temperaturen sinken auf 12 grad in
ostbayern oder auch an der nordsee und
bis 4 grad im sauerland
das ist so kalt dass sich dort sogar
nochmal etwas nebel oder dunst bildet
über den nordosten ziehen einige wolken
hinweg und an der ostseeküste kann es
auch nochmal leicht schauern und auch
morgen gibt es einige wolkenfelder die
hier über den nordosten ziehen sonst
aber strahlt die sonne steigen die
temperaturen im südwesten auf 23 bis 29
grad im nordosten bleibt es bei 18 bis
23 grad etwas kühler aber das ändert
sich bis samstag wird es von tag zu tag
wärmer und am sonnabend sind die
temperaturen an der küste bei 22 bis 24
grad angekommen sonst aber im binnenland
geht es auf 29 bis 36 grad rauf und dazu
ist es doch meist trocken und allenfalls
am donnerstag an fronleichnam kann es in
den alpen aus den alpen heraus mal ein
kleines gewitter geben schön amt